a lot of reaction to the President's
speech last night but none more worthy
of its own segment than that of New
Democratic congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez and here's why
the president should not be asking for
more money to an agency that has
systematically violated human rights the
president should be really defending why
we are funding such an agency at all
because right now what we are seeing is
death right now what we are seeing is
the violation of human rights but she
didn't just stop at that slamming eyes
she took it to a whole other level with
this he's fighting against almost every
way that people can actually legally
enter this country forcing them to
become undocumented and then he's trying
to attack their undocumented status this
is systemic it is wrong and it is
anti-american those women and children
trying to come here with nothing but the
shirts on their back to create an
opportunity and to provide for this
nation are acting more in an American
tradition than this president is right
now all right Jesse she was subjected to
some journalists to criticism over this
obviously and defended herself against
being called vacas how do you reconcile
how would she reconcile that with such
seemingly arguable mindless comments
well as someone who's been called
vacuous I can sympathize I'm getting a
OC fatigue she's everywhere she's on 60
minutes she's on MSNBC she's all over
the internet I'm kind of over it already
think about what she's saying she's
saying that the illegal aliens are more
American than the President of the
United States
she's a reverse birther okay the
opposite of what Trump said and now
she's saying that ice agents are
committing human rights violations ice
agents are the actual people that
apprehend illegal immigrants for
committing human rights violations like
child sex trafficking and homicide and
things like that she's saying in the
midst of decades best wage growth GDP
growth and unemployment hey you know
what capitalism capitalism isn't working
let's try socialism it's the kind of
stuff you hear your average College
Democrats say and you kind of just roll
your eyes but now she's a member of
Congress
training wheels are off she's popping
wheelies through the country throwing
hand grenades out there she's a problem
not for Republicans she's a problem for
Pelosi that's what I think a problem for
Schumer but she's Chuck or Nancy whoever
she's a delightful Republican parent
well she's good for ratings here at Fox
I think all over the conservative media
universe they seem to the light and what
they call it AOC now but I I must tell
you though guess what the American
people agree with her oh that we are a
socialist country now I don't earns the
American people say the Republicans are
responsible for this shutdown and
secondly that when it comes to
separating families and children from
parents Americans don't like it
Americans think they want to open
borders I think when people say oh you
know what these people come and
sometimes steer families and workers
with these raids remember when
Republicans said about ATF jackbooted
thugs well guess what imagine if you're
an immigrant and you see your
grandmother or your cousin being raided
and taken away you think oh my god
so I think looking said that when the
guns were sold Dana you were saying that
it's more of a problem for Shermer yes I
just so the Democrats are already trying
to get their 2020 game going and they
have their Super hopeful they think that
they can make Trump a one-term president
okay so we'll see how that goes but but
if they don't win back the Senate they
will not be in a position of power it is
really difficult and I think that for
Pelosi where the energy is in the party
right now it helps in the house to have
AOC out there and all of these things
that they don't have to defend them that
much but if you actually want to have
power in the country you have to win
back the Senate and I think that the
more she's out there the more difficult
it is for Chuck Schumer to try to make
any gains on the Republicans and that
they're more likely in 2020 Republicans
more likely to keep the Senate or
actually even expand the number of seats
that they have Greg yes what would the
messaging be for compassionate more
moderate Democrats who don't agree that
the human rights violations and
just death with ice and that there's
some type of moderate ground that
includes the reality of the human rights
violations being committed by those
being apprehended by those at the border
etc I don't want I don't want to help
them out no I would actually say I would
actually say that you know she's okay
she is the Democratic Party's Trump in
the sense that she is galvanizing social
media via extreme and memorable
pronouncements every morning she gets up
and she says what's my locker up
what's my what's my build the wall and
she comes up with something every day
that like ends up on shows like this but
I think she is she's betraying her
constituency illegal immigration affects
the wages it affects the job market of
minorities that's what that is a
stone-cold fact and and it is what it is
and you can't the stone-cold fact is
that immigration actually helps economic
growth categorically low wages
non-compliance with people on the left
this reminds me of like mitt romney's
gardeners and and Trump people at
Trump's properties that being so oh yeah
I guess we're illegal immigrants oh well
I don't follow that what I'm saying is
that have a sheep labor hurts minorities
or people that are on the lower rung of
the ladder trying to get a job you can
pop all you want want that's a fact yeah
so the problem is let me finish why
because you talked a bit okay um it's we
have to get over the fact of Logan
excuse me being sexist if you criticize
her it's actually sexist if you don't
criticize her yeah that's fit you've got
to go up and you got to say your ideas
are old you're refreshing and you're in
your delivery you're young you're
exciting but your ideas are as dead as
the socialism of the past but you know
what she's doing something and she's not
taking the traditional heat that you'd
expect when you call a sitting president
on America yeah or you advocate for
socialism or you demean a law
enforcement a couple years ago I'm old
enough to remember doing those things
you'd get hit pretty hard
I mean this is what they can just build
the Blasio School of demmer I think you
know you that had been done to Obama by
by isolated Republicans a congressman a
few congressmen I think we can remember
it's accusing President Obama have not
being American and all that stuff so I
think hurt for that yeah there's a
mirror a perfect mirror image to
everything on these parties that's the
sad thing is that one side does exactly
what the other side does that's why
there's so much redundancy I think I
should have had her do the response
because then they would have had to
communicate with her a little bit and to
channel it and to take all of this great
energy and try to put it in the director
further Nancy and Chuck response